this week on quadriga refugee crisis
where is the compassion thousands of
refugees adrift on flimsy boats in the
Indian Ocean initially Thailand Malaysia
and Indonesia sent the refugees back to
see declaring they would not take any
more in many of the refugees who are
mostly from Myanmar and Bangladesh have
been on perilous journeys for months
those who have reached safety have told
harrowing tales of fights over food
under pressure from the UN Malaysia and
Indonesia have now agreed to offer
temporary shelter coming to you from
Berlin quadriga your host this week
Melinda crane hello and welcome critics
say the operative word there is
temporary that the agreement reached
this week is a short-term fix to a
long-term problem refugee crisis where
is the compassion that's the question
we're posing this week on quadriga and
let's get some answers now from our
guests Arica Hammond is business editor
of the Berlin newspaper the tots she
says refugees are seen as a burden we
need to take the sense of migration
overload seriously and it's a pleasure
to welcome your highness Latoya he
covers politics for the German newspaper
the Frankfurter Allgemeine it's item
previously served as its London
correspondent he says the international
community must increase the pressure and
Sanjeev Gorman he is a German with
Indian roots who works on the DW
Southeast Asia desk as a member of its
Bengali team he says we have to fight
the causes and not the symptoms so let's
start then by taking a look at the
causes 7,000 to 8,000 people are
apparently still at sea in the flimsiest
possible boats mr. Berman why are they
fleeing who are the migrants and what
provokes the desperation that we've seen
to get into these kind of of boats and
and push out to sea there are quite a
lot of people who are out on the sea we
are not even sure where the 7,000 or
even more but we're talking about 7,000
people most of them have fled from the
rakhine state of President Myanmar
though they have been living there for a
long time although the Burmese
recognize them as a official minority
they don't even have election remedy
they don't have voting rights they are
allowed to have only two children and
they have been persecuted for a very
long time and along with them there are
some Bangladesh's also you have to
remember the South drawing as our
refugees in Bangladesh and some other
Bangladesh's have also joined in this
influx where they're being picked up by
smaller boats which look like Fisher
boats so nothing to feel you know
they're not really at getting attention
and they're being brought out into the
high sea into a bigger boats and along
the Myanmar course they're being taken
to Thailand you know by lots of groups
who are asking for money or selling them
off as slaves as well and very verda
code they're getting money from the
relatives and wherever not they're being
sold as slaves sometimes for the
Thailand fish industry rather you is now
trying to threaten to boycott the fish
coming out of Thailand so that's more or
less the complex situation right now
where we get Herman until this agreement
that was reached on Wednesday the
various countries in the region were
basically saying no we are not going to
take these people in in fact they were
even said to be towing the boats back
out to sea after giving them a bit of
water and food now your statement that I
quoted earlier referred to migration
overload generally when countries refuse
to take people in it's because they're
perceived as economic migrants people
who are looking for a better life
prosperity but the fact is these people
seem to be fleeing for their lives in
fact most refugees always flee for their
life it's not true that people usually
leave their countries just to find more
riches somewhere else you can really
show that people almost always go if
there is no possibility to survive at
home so it is an ideology ideological
concept to tell people that they were
just looking for a better life it's
always almost always a question of
survival now when I said that it is
something cultural I meant that we speak
about just 7,000 people that's just
nothing that's more or less a village
alone Indonesia has more than 130
million inhabitants so what are 7,000
just nothing but still already just
7,000 people are being regarded as a
dangerous group and that's something
that you have to deal with politically
it's not an economic question at all I'd
like to talk about another cause that we
focused on a great deal here in Europe
with the European crisis with refugees
and in fact it's certainly at work in
Southeast Asia as well namely human
trafficking here there has been loud
calls for a crackdown on human
trafficking but in fact Johannes light
wiser a crackdown helped to prompt this
latest crisis well I think you're right
in there but I think the one the states
that are taking or not taking these
refugees in only one part of this of
this setting that is to blame I think
you have to look as well to to the side
where these refugees come from and they
are huge differences and I think there's
a big difference between Africa which is
our problem now because people are
crossing the Mediterranean and Asia and
if you look at me n ma this is a state
that just does many things to try to
come back into the international
community they are opening up they want
to be seen as a state to of doing
reforms giving a paving away to
democracy and I think they have to be
taken to account what is happening there
to their minority and it's not only that
we have to deal with the consequences we
have to look at the source of the
problems well let us in fact then take a
closer look at Myanmar and at the row
hinder or ro hingga people who are being
persecuted there the Rajah are a Muslim
minority in predominantly Buddhist
Myanmar
state not only doesn't recognize a row
hinder but also denies them citizenship
most live in abject poverty are
unemployed and had very few rights
nearly 1 million row hinder live in
Myanmar mostly in rakhine state near the
Bangladeshi border most lead the country
by boat heading for neighboring
Indonesia Malaysia and Thailand in the
last three months alone some twenty
eight and a half thousand people are
believed to have fled Myanmar calamos
our president in Myanmar doesn't like
Muslims he says he will put us in jail
for 20 30 or 40 years pick up a load on
it to myself again and again the row
Hinda have been the target of
religiously and ethnically motivated
violence in June of 2012 whole villages
were torched during unrest in Raccoon
state Sanjeev Berman the UN said this
week that the row hingga are among the
most persecuted people in the world now
it's a cliche perhaps but many people in
the West think of Buddhism as a religion
of tolerance of peace and certainly
young saeng Suchi who is a leader in
Myanmar as a Nobel Prize winner as also
as a person of peace so explain the
paradox for us how can this kind of
persecution be occurring in Myanmar yeah
indeed sounds like invited us very much
because miyama has been a very peaceful
country I me not in terms of material
but as such as people but it is also
very complex society with more or less
135 recognized minorities ethnic
minorities would live there and in 1982
there was a law which for bed the ruling
gasps as you know they're not recognized
give addie kind of franchise and they're
not supposed to vote and they have all
the restrictions and and there's a
Buddhist movement also led by a monk in
in Mandalay who has been trying to
propagate that the Muslims are trying to
take over the Buddhist Myanmar in coming
over from Bengal they say it I mean
they're not recognized as we
who have been living there for quite not
thousands of years but quite a few
hundred years at least I mean when those
estate call Eric on which is modern-day
Rakhine province and this has been
happening quite a lot and so there's a
popular resentment against the Muslims
as being portrayed by the Buddhist monks
and widely being kind of perceived as
threats so there's not a lot of popular
sentiment father growing us on the other
hand on some sushi is also being very
cautious politically because this is the
year when the elections are supposed to
take place and she's a candidate she
wants to become the president she also
doesn't really want to talk against them
and she herself said that if I talk on
behalf of throwing us now they may be
even they may come under mapa more
brutal persecution and that's why I'm
kind of falling back but this morning
the her party members have been forced
to take a stand and has been appealing
to the government to do something about
them and to kind of be compassionate to
show compassion at least but the
question here and it's the same question
we posed when we look at the Middle East
is this really about religion or is it
about power and politics it's certainly
about power and politics because you
have to remember the Myanmar also has a
lot of other problems with the chain
catching rebels and lots of rebel groups
were operating at the border the Chinese
I think yesterday across the Chinese
border there was bombardments from the
Myanmar side and also the Thai borders
has been very very sensitive so there's
no authority even the military authority
India Myanmar doesn't really have a
control over the entire country right
now so after the one thing I can think
of is a federal model like in Germany or
in Europe there which would be the final
solution when things come to normal
Myanmar can always survive if they have
a kind of a more or less lose federal
system where which takes care of the
problems of all the minorities that
could be one of the solutions maybe we
did see some concession by Myanmar today
you had a slight wiser you said in your
opening statement that i quoted more
pressure needs to be brought on Myanmar
and you just said that here as well do
you think it was the pressure that has
brought those concessions from Myanmar
and do we do we need to keep it up can
we really change the internal
politics of me and Martha that were just
described I think that's hard to say
whatever the motive has been and perhaps
i should add it's not only pressure it's
more than that it should be more
engagement by the western country or by
the international community by regional
organizations there's this group of
asian states called asian group that
sees the you as a role model for many
things certainly for trade relations and
others they should act indonesia and
malaysia are members of this group as
well so they have a responsibility to
take refugees that are in danger and in
parallel at sea but again they have a
responsibility to to talk to myanmar as
well and and we do have a responsibility
to help them to sort out these problems
that might get worse and worse maybe the
Rangers are just escape goat for
internal struggles and power struggles
but if nothing is done this could
escalate in many ways and when the
dictatorship loses its grip of the
country it has to be replaced by sound
and stable other institutions democratic
institutions we would like to see that
can deal with these problems on our
ethnic problems on a more peaceful and
and conciliatory way but this needs so
often the West is holding back end is
only acting when it's too late and so
perhaps we need to have a fine a sense
of what we can do that not only the west
of course working to hammond but also
the countries in the region neither
myanmar nor bangladesh protests
participated in the talks that were held
earlier this week and as i just
mentioned myanmar has now made a
concession or two they've said they will
go to a regional meeting on the
twenty-ninth of may but they said
they're only going to do that if nobody
puts the blame on them for the crisis
and if nobody calls the RO hingga people
row Inga's we're supposed to call them
bengalis well that sounds plain crazy
and it is crazy but I think when it
comes to the influence of potential
influence of the Western world the basic
problem is that many of the problems
were
host in a way by the Western world when
they were still colonial powers they
were booking us for example where most
of them settled in myanmar by the
english when they were the colonial
power 150 years ago and the same applies
in a way to Syria but you can see there
is that a colonial rulings when it came
to border lines and so on and now
unfolding and it is kind of in a way of
course I agree that the Western world
should somehow engage and try to solve
the problem but in a way it's really
paradoxical to think that the Western
world should solve problems that it had
caused itself but isn't there a point at
which countries own their own problems
orica ham and colonialism was a long
time ago well it is not that long ago no
it's just 60 years ago oh it's it's a
it's a and not as long as the ago as the
second world war in Germans still feel
responsible for what they did in the
Second World War so you know it is but
we would credit ourselves that we have
developed in some cases and and we will
find other tools and measures then then
the the ones that were applied 50 or 100
years ago so if you if you if you don't
like the term the West then we could say
the international community the United
Nations whoever but there has to be some
some some outer force helping them out
Sanjeev Verma perhaps give us a bit more
insight on why governments in the region
have been so reluctant to take real
measures to try to get at the roots of
the crisis or at least to help those who
were at sea what's behind the dithering
that we've seen but before that we have
to remember that it's the government's
in the beginning played a very minimal
law roll I mean when the refugees
arrived it was the fishermen of Archie
who first received the refugees very
innovative very human i think i would
say approach and they were given food
and shelter and to start with it was a
very nice gesture and then only the
authorities were alarmed that these
people have arrived and then only these
people coming
the player to the game it's not like
Europe where the government's other you
know the prime players who really take
part in you know the Melfi the
government and the coastal guard they do
all of the things and here it's just a
very spontaneous thing which came out
from the people and you also remember
that boat Malaysian and anisha there
muslim-majority countries and achieves
the province where religious sentiments
are very high so they kind of first
embraced him as Muslim brothers fleeing
persecution so that also played a role
and incidentally today we heard that
West African country Gambia also wants
to take over all the refugees if there
if somebody can bring them there and
help them are subtle there because
they're Muslims so that also kind of
played a role and both Thailand Thailand
Malaysia and Indonesia all three
countries have certain problems some in
his of history when it came to refugees
so they're being also very cautious I
mean talent has in the South its own
Muslim insurgency so they're very
cautious about accepting Muslim refugees
without knowing what would sport that
would mean for the balance of power and
Indonesia has also been very careful
malaysia of course a lot of ringers who
lived there their economic migrants were
being kind at the sold off their as
slaves or as proper legal refugees who
live there so they'd also don't want to
have a big change they could come you
know it's for them it's not seven
thousand people if the gate opens they
aren't scared that about 1.3 million to
1.5 million people who live right now in
rakhine state and in Bangladesh as
refugees what happens if they get
encouraged and come in mass and go to
richer countries like Malaysia Indonesia
as you just mentioned while the
government's were dithering the
fishermen of Akshay were taking matters
into their own hands let's take a look
at the people who were the first to
offer compassion to the refugees who
were adrift
Indonesian and Malaya Sherman are acting
while their politicians are still
debating for days now these fishermen
have been helping the refugees from
Myanmar when they find people they bring
them on board give them water and food
and ferry them to shore many of these
migrants are completely exhausted under
the suspicious eyes of the authorities
they receive further care the Malaysian
Coast Guard has so far been actively
keeping the boat people from reaching
the shore now the politicians have been
forced into action the foreign ministers
of the affected states finally met
spurred on by rising public pressure
Indonesia and Malaysia agreed to
continue to provide humanitarian
assistance who goes 7,000 irregular
migrants still at sea we also agreed to
offer them temporary shelter provided
that the settlement and repatriation
process will be done in one year by the
international community the problem is
that Myanmar doesn't want the migrants
back for the refugees that means their
Odyssey could be far from over and
you're watching quadriga refugee crisis
where is the compassion well clearly
there was some compassion there on the
part of the fisherman but the
neighboring states orica hammond have
not shown a whole lot of compassion if
you listen to the terms of that
settlement that were just described
temporary shelter repatriation within
one year and Thailand for example has
not taken in any of the refugees at
least so far it has not promised to do
so is this a workable solution well
oppositely it is not and I mean that's
really the problem what could be a good
solution because it's true that the
neighboring countries are really afraid
that once they take in some of the
refugees that even more refugees might
be coming and that in the end they sit
have about a million refugees of coming
from Myanmar I think the only
possibility would be an international
solution not to Western solution because
as I said we are part of the problem and
of course it would be easier if some
he was paid because then you know people
would not have this feeling that these
refugees were an economic threat usually
they are not I mean we have lots of
migration when it comes labour migration
it's much more important than the
refugees refugees are just a very small
minority when it comes to international
migration so in a way it is completely
and people are afraid for something they
don't have to be afraid of the perhaps
it would ease the process if you gave
some money so that they have the feeling
okay we are being paid for being
hospitable Johannes lighter the question
of whether rescue and shelter can act as
an incentive for even more migrants to
come is of course question that's been
debated at great length here in Europe
as well the operation on the
Mediterranean that was stopped because
it was rescuing people would stop partly
because some countries like Britain said
this will be an incentive to even more
people to leave North Africa and try to
cross the Mediterranean do you think
that's right I think that's true but
this is a this is a fact that doesn't
leave you doesn't doesn't encourage you
to draw conclusions you have to rescue
the people that are in peril etsy there
is no way around this and you can't
ignore it by just not going where they
are drowning so because otherwise you
you are guilty as well so we have to we
have to pick them up and bring to bring
them ashore this is we can't we can't
stop doing this because we're thinking
it's we just will act as a pull factor
and bring more people to us but i think
yes i mean the the refugees on the
southern shore of the Mediterranean are
there for all kinds of reasons they are
Syrians fleeing from the civil war
that's going on in their own country
there are people from sub-saharan Africa
that are sent by their village community
that there and they they collect money
to pay the trafficker to bring them to
Europe and in in the hope that they will
be rewarded bye-bye money that is sent
sent back sometimes so clearly the hope
is they will make it to Europe and if
they make it and send someone
but they are setting an example others
will follow okay Kevin are you sure that
it really is a PO factor you told us
before that people are fleeing in
desperation and for their lives are they
really doing a cost-benefit calculus
before they get into boats well most of
them clearly go because they do not have
any survival chance at home you can see
that if you see that about a billion
people have not enough to eat and you
have only 50 million refugees you can
see immediately that most people stay at
home even in very dire situations those
who go those who are mostly very very
desperate of course there are some cases
like those villages in Africa who
collect money in order to make one of
them go abroad but even then they
usually are very very poor and have no
other possibility to somehow secure
their future now when it comes to Europe
of course we could take in lots of Mario
games without suffering for example
Germany needs about five hundred
thousand migrants every year just to
remain stable to do have a stable
working force because so many baby
boomers now retire but we do not have
enough employees anymore so five hundred
thousand it's a lot and even with all
those refugees that we had to take in we
still do not reach this limit so we
could really invest in a way in migrants
but we don't do that but not for
economic reasons people always think
it's something about sharing their
wealth and such stuff that's complete
nonsense it's this culture of fear
that's irrational that once there are so
many Americans coming that you somehow
lose your German asst or whatever yes
but you can't I mean yeah but I mean
that's the fact I mean it's maybe maybe
it is irrational with you I think you
can't you can't teach society there and
and say is a politician look you have
all these silly fears you know they are
completely unfounded and that's why we
will settle I don't know how many
migrants next to your door if you do
this you will just create social riots
or whatever
for economic reasons but for other
reasons so there has be there there
limits to what you can what you can do
even if you know you should do it
because of economic or humanitarian
reasons I want to come back shortly to
the question of settling refugees but
perhaps a brief look in a bit more
detail at efforts to stop them from even
getting into boats I asked Johannes
light eyes are a bit earlier Santi
Foreman about the role of traffickers in
fact there was an effort recently in
Southeast Asia to crack down on
trafficking it seems to have been
counterproductive in the sense that the
traffickers then simply left their
charges in the boats to drift and drown
what can be done against trafficking
it's a question here as well when we
look at the crisis in the Mediterranean
yeah when you look at the South Ossetia
and the traffic is there they are very
smart I mean first of all they've come
from all countries all the countries we
are talking about Bangladesh Myanmar
Thailand and all of them have their
local basis then exactly how to deal
with the people and how to bring the
people they are smaller boats which pick
up the desperate people they go to the
bigger boats they hand it over to the
next people and there's a fixed sum of
money there's a reporter who went in
there to find out wonder what kind of
money we are talking about and they
found out how much is spayed and every
time each one is handed over and then to
the jungle camp in Thailand when they
are again hand it over what that you
know how about what that means and who
are useful people who they can make
money out of where there are slaves or
as somebody who could drink some ransom
from the families whatever little money
they've got left so this is the
structure which is going all across this
problematic area and I think the states
are still not really in a position even
if they wanted to even if they had the
good will to really crack down on the on
these traffickers so I keep saying that
it's much more important to fight the
cause in the rakhine state in Myanmar
maybe with twist need and maybe not just
with man it's not a question of money
also it's also to teach the people how
to deal with this threat you know when
you think that these are really
outsiders they are not people of me at
all I mean maybe some sort of
development projects or something which
you know makes it easier for them to
live there where they
out there and miss me on my authority
that you know that and assured them as
well that you know the international
committee will be with them engage with
them to make sure that the threats which
are prevalent are not really you know
actual dress that will never happen so
as long as if you can keep the people
there in their own land and you know in
whatever little means they need require
that would prevent the traffickers like
like what we say what Europe that in if
you make legal immigration pasal in
Europe the you know you don't need the
traffickers because nobody will go to
them I mean if you have a way of doing
get interesting done well it's also like
the argument in Europe saying we need
better development efforts in Africa so
that people will stay where they are
Johannes light wiser at best those are
very very long term prospects and we've
got a big short-term crisis yeah but
again it depends on the region you are
looking at i would say you can you can
have success in a more easy way in Asia
and in the region we are talking about
today and I would agree if you look at
Africa you'll lead you clearly in need
of a longer term approach because when
you look at some northern African states
like Libya that there is no government
left here that's not not a state anymore
in our conventional where we are
thinking of states so and that that's
one of the reasons why the europeans are
so keen to to show some some some state
and legal action in this suggestions to
go there and destroy both of the
traffickers because clear there is no
other authority that can do anything to
stop the traffickers from trafficking
i'm not sure it will prevent any any
refugees coming or being sent out to sea
it's a for me it's quite a helpless sign
but it is a sign politicians would like
to set to to come the opinion in their
own countries in europe or BK hammond
many people say we're facing a new age
of
migration and the world has been through
great waves of migration before but are
we prepared and ready and willing to
handle this as we perhaps were at other
times in human history oh well I mean
it's a kind of paradox that the
Europeans who somehow settled all over
the world in North America South America
Australia and New Zealand and who mostly
somehow eradicated the original people
now think that they cannot take anyone
after having a set of the whole world
but as I said it is not an economic
problem in a German alone could need
needs about five hundred thousand
immigrants every year it is a cultural
problem and what is really it there's it
yeah if I hear what all of you are
saying we are talking about a major
governance crisis it's like many hearts
yeah exactly in the world so the age of
migration goes hand-in-hand with an age
of bad governance yeah exactly and if
you can see that in Germany how a small
problem relatively small problem is
being made worse by the government
because here it's the villages and towns
that are somehow responsible for housing
the refugees for them it's of course a
surplus expenditure but they don't have
any money for and the talents and small
communities they cannot somehow decide
to have new taxes or to take on loans or
deaths that's not allowed but the
national government could easily pay for
all the refugees without any problem but
they don't do that so you're now we have
always this discussion on the local
level about communities that are not
able to house the refugees that they
send to them now of course everyone in
Germany has this idea well these
refugees are really very expensive and
they are really a very very big problem
but in fact the problem is being created
politically and that is really now of
course because the communities don't
know what to do it's always in the media
and the whole topic it gets bigger and
bigger and bigger without being big
because you know in the 90s Germany
integrated more than two million
refugees or
migrants from Russia and it was no
problem at all because they were
regarded to be Germans treated as
Germans and they integrated so it advice
really stupid well you've outlined the
difficulties that people are facing here
in Germany but the fact is Germany has
taken in a great many more migrants than
many other countries within the European
Union let us take a look at the most
recent European Union proposals
unsettling migrants just five EU
countries among them Italy Germany and
Sweden are taking in over half of the
refugees but in the future a quota
system is meant to spread the load more
evenly between the 28 EU states the
system set criteria to distribute some
20,000 refugees to the EU countries but
the EU plan is running into serious
opposition some key countries like
Britain and France as well as Poland and
Hungary have rejected a quota system
johanna slight wiser is this a real
solution to the question of what to do
about the refugees certainly Germany
feels that it has borne a
disproportionate share of the burden o
Rica Hammond on the other hand tells us
Germany could take in a whole lot more
well yeah but um we like to be European
and to be seen as good Europeans and
especially so if there is a suggestion
or a solution that lifts some of the
burden we're taking off our shoulders so
the compromise that had been reached or
the proposal the European Commission has
made is that refugees should be
distributed within the European Union
according to and the the population
numbers numbers of unemployment and
other figures of the Member States and
that would mean that we would have to
take less refugees in the future than we
did in the past so of course we are
happy there are many other countries
that would have to take more they tried
somehow to to bow out or to find excuses
excuses why they don't have to to come
to the table or be part of this
agreement that's all normal politics i
would say that nothing special you can
find this in many areas of politics
where things go according to these
mechanisms the only difference here is
that we're dealing with real people in
distress and we there's there's a moral
moral area to this or model platform and
when you're standing on this and you
look at what's going on you feel a bit
taken aback and shame okay man you did
say in the statement that I quoted at
the outset of the program that we need
to take the sense of cultural overload
seriously of immigration overload the
fact is there is rising anti-immigration
sentiment in almost every country in the
European Union so your arguments based
on economics they may be valid but
clearly they're not coming home to
people yeah exactly i mean that's why i
said that you had really have to take
seriously that it is a culture
a problem and not an in economic prof so
what is that yeah because usually it's
been treated as an economic problem
people are being told if you take all
these refugees it's going to be very
really really expensive and we can't
afford that that's [ __ ] it's all
about culture about fears that somehow
you could lose control and all that all
these corners somehow rule your country
and whatever and these cultural fears
have to be taken seriously but if you
want to take them seriously one very
important fact would be I think two
things first is we have a great
inequality within Europe there are very
many poor people and a few very rich
people who own almost everything now if
you have this very big inequality people
at the bottom of course fear that they
might suffer if foreigners come in who
then take their jobs or something like
that it would be much easier for Europe
to accept foreigners if the equality
within the countries was a greater so I
think if you have to do something about
the inequality in Europe and the second
point is that you have to somehow find
political solutions that make it
possible that the the issue of migrants
is not every day and every day and every
day on the front page of the newspapers
because once they are kind of this topic
is permanently within the media people
of course think oh it is a very big
issue a very big problem and we are
being overrun by refugees and be somehow
must stop these refugees from coming
from coming um yeah well yeah i would
like to to disagree first we're getting
that leads us bit off-topic now I think
in in societies that are more unequal
than Germany is for instance Great
Britain they they have a less problems
taking in migrants all day against the
gutter I'm more used to migration now
there there's that there's a certain
twist now in recent years whereas we in
Germany are quite and at least since the
Second World War we are quieter that's
an equal society a level society I would
say and and we are more there's there's
a lot talk at least about anxieties of
having too many foreign people coming in
because we don't we want to go
everywhere in our country
feel at home everywhere when you are in
London and you are a white well of
person they are three thirds of three
fourth of the city you don't dare to do
to to go to because that's not your
London that's a London belonging to
other people we don't so in a way I
think we have that's now we are in the
middle of these cultural problems we are
facing from migration and that's that's
one of the underlying reasons
politicians have to deal with when they
make judgments about whom we can take
and whom we can't sanjeev foreman our
title asks that question where is the
compassion you know both cultures very
well this one in the West and also the
one of Southeast Asia which side society
is more compassionate of the to do you
see more compassion in the way people
here are dealing with migrants than the
ones been and how they're being dealt
with in Southeast Asia well when we talk
about the discourse in the media I mean
which is about the perception you know
like what what people think and all the
right populist movements in Europe who
are trying to really make use of this
fear so much and where the mainstream
parties that i think i would say that I
really disappointed that the Christian
Democratic Union or Indian in the sense
that in all the European countries you
know the movement the party the
Conservatives are so to say are not
really doing the best to you know
educate the people their electorate our
are addressing the issues so whenever
the mainstream parties start stop
addressing the issues that they go off
to the I to the far left or the far
right which is happening quite a lot in
Europe mostly the far right and that is
creating a lot of problem but on the
ground level i would say people are
generally much more compassionate i mean
when it comes to people normal ordinary
people even in germany or as when europe
they are i think much more open when it
when they're not talking in terms of the
overall development you know of migrants
coming in and out of that but if they
have an even right in the front i think
it and if the talk most of the problem
arises when they don't talk when they
talk when things start walking out then
of course they say okay i don't mean you
i mean i mean the other people you know
are people out there the more abstract
they are the more threatening the kind
of feel look like so you see the eastern
part of germany
which has hardly had any migrants at all
the other that's the place where you
have the right wing parties winning more
votes although they are nothing to do
with the migrants the foreigners if you
go to the western part of Germany they
have been dealing with Turks and other
minorities for a long time with all the
dealings and everything people are much
more educated they know from their own
experience how these other people are
and as less tension and they're very
much a part of this society integration
is very complicated what but one can see
that the people are more integrated in
places where they are many and they have
been dealing with each other in spite of
the government the government has a much
less role to play there and Southeast
Asia is of course is a very society
where the state is virtually
non-existent and people take things into
their own hand they don't depend on the
state or a minister saying this or that
it's it's basically what they think is
right so their compassion goes out like
in the case of the fishermen they don't
care about the government saying do this
or do that they have been doing what
they think is right so we done well I
get home on one solution that the EU is
now talking about this week which
doesn't sound very compassionate at all
is the further militarization of the
Mediterranean namely the use of naval
ships to intercept illegal refugee boats
how concerned are you that that provides
an extremely negative precedent
essentially a signal also for the rest
of the world including Southeast Asia
well I think it is a helpless guest sure
it will nothing will be achieved the
writ and the only thing that will happen
is that the risk for the refugees will
be higher it will have even more people
drowning because they take more risky
routes but you can't keep people who are
desperate from coming to Europe you know
in the late 1970s Johannes latosa we had
a boat people crisis of enormous
proportions in Asia and the world
community found a solution for it that
is not happening this time around where
is the compassion why isn't it happening
and well it was very very different
times than and the refugees you're
talking with
vietnamese and there was this war going
on in vietnam and that was kind of a
proxy World War there were the two big
systems the Communist Soviet empire and
America and the West fighting each other
so we had to prove something they're
armed and well it's difficult to say
this but the refugees then were not seen
only us not even in the first place as a
humanitarian problem or need to help but
they were seen as political refugees
every one of them was a proof that the
world of freedom was more attractive
than the Soviet empire so of course we
embraced them and and and it they've
been proven to be a success story as
well I mean one of one of them has been
the chairman of a party in Germany
recently so they really have marched
through society in our country and I
hope that to some extent they are able
to repeat this but on different terms
and with different connotations sanji
furman we will see an international
meeting in one week in Southeast Asia to
try to resolve this in one sentence will
we see more compassion there well false
compassion one can see that they'll be
forced to take actions which would in
the short term solved about a little bit
but they have to be for a much bigger
effort to really address the problem in
a bigger way thank you very much thanks
to all of you for being with us thanks
to you out there for tuning in see you
soon
you